as children return to the classroom
scientists have warned of an increase in
covert 19 cases
so should we be worried
i'm looking forward to having a full
year in class i hope nice to get back to
a bit more normality and getting back to
school and doing the things we do
playing football with the lads
in the coming months a greater
proportion of the coronavirus cases
reported are likely to be from children
as adults have been prioritized in the
vaccine rollout with children with the
greatest love in the world they
effectively act as bio terrorists they
spread viruses amongst themselves on a
regular basis
and then they bring it home to us in
scotland cases have spiked particularly
in those under 18 as the delta variant
circulates and schools have reopened
though the number of young people in
hospital has not increased experts warn
we could expect to see cases increase
across all age groups
two things happen when schools open one
is obvious young people mix the other
thing we know from research and polling
is that when you take your kids to
school
you can mix
so adult contact also increases when
schools go back because there's less
child care required so the whole of
society has a bump when schools go back
and that adult group is what worries us
actually more than the young people
coronavirus does affect children but
less frequently and seriously than
adults those aged between 1 and 18 have
much lower rates of hospitalization and
death compared with any other age group
they often don't develop any symptoms at
all those they do get tend to be mild
such as a cough fever or fatigue the
vast majority will make a very rapid
recovery and for the children as a whole
there is very little to worry about
there is some interesting research out
just today that's suggesting that
children however are at risk of long
covid in some rare cases children have
developed multi-system inflammatory
syndrome or misc
what happens there is their body fights
covid and once it's finished fighting
covid the body turns on itself
and all of that inflammation then turns
about causing cardiac inflammation
kidneys can become inflamed the lungs
become inflamed the numbers of this with
the original variants were extremely
rare we were talking um less than one in
a million cases of that incredibly rare
what we still don't know however is
whether the delta variant the new
variant that's now in circulation is
going to increase the risk of that
i'm looking forward to actually being
able to see different classes as
children return to the classroom many of
the restrictions in place before the
summer have now gone there will be no
more bubbles no more bubbles
or isolation for someone who comes into
contact with someone with covid
now students will just have to take a
pcr test and only isolate if that test
comes back positive home testing will
continue for secondary school students
and there will be twice weekly natural
flows
i'm really really happy um i'm pleased
that he's coming this year and not last
year to be honest i think it's time now
i think children have missed out
[Music]
in the u.s the center for disease
control has recommended children over
the age of 12 be vaccinated and the fda
has authorized the pfizer jab in those
age 12 and above it's also been
authorized by the uk's jcvi though at
the moment only children between 16 and
18 can get the jab
some believe they'd be better used
elsewhere
if our aim is to reduce the number of
deaths and hospitalizations then booster
jabs are definitely
what we should be prioritizing above
vaccinating children because i think
there's a there's a limited supply of
vaccines and you're not able to do
everything you want to do but if we want
to try and drive down the total number
of cases then we need to go into
children
[Music]
the more infectious a variant is the
greater chance it has of spreading among
adults as well as children a variant
could be more infectious in children for
several reasons including how many
copies of itself a virus could make
so the delta variant can make nearly a
thousand times more copies of itself per
um infected cell than the previous
variants now we're in a position where
they can generate enough copies that if
they cough in our direction it may be
picked up
or how well the key of the virus fits
into the lock of your cells that's the
spike protein attaching to the ace2
now the delta variant has a very good
key
that key can fit into the lock very very
easily that means you need a lower dose
of the virus to infect themselves
with children that means that previously
their immune system was that active it
could get rid of the virus before it
took hold
the threat of new more infectious
variants means the approach to
containing the virus could change